And so I sort of did process of elimination on this one. Let's see.
If it starts up here, that means the velocity is 0, right?
Well it can't be the blue graph because the blue graph starts with some positive velocity
likewise the green starts with some negative.
That just doesn't make sense. We know it starts at rest as both the pink and the red do.
Look at the difference here. The red immediately goes towards negative velocity.
The pink goes towards positive. What actually happens? Well it goes downwards.
Of course it goes downwards. We're dropping it.
So it's actually the red graph is the best answer.
There's a lot more to say about these graphs.
Ways to manipulate them and change the amplitude period
shift them and a lot of interesting stuff to learn.
We're not going to cover it in this class. Maybe in a later one.
But you should definitely read up on it on your own if it's something you're interested in.
But these graphs sort of highlight the periodic nature of simple harmonic motion.
They just repeat themselves over and over and over,
and that's exactly the property we want from a chronometer.
We want it to be able to repeat itself.
We want to know that every period is the same length of time.
One tick of the clock. Now, the real question is, how do we control what this period is?